for the final segment of your evening
music that intrigues us the Griffin Trio
has teamed up with digital artist jacqu
colan and mcmaster's Live Lab to give
you a window into your mind as it is
responding to music the trio will play
the first movement from Beethoven's Arch
duuk Trio while jacqu provides a
creative representation of brain waves
ahead of time at the Live Lab the EEG
data was captured while a subject was
listening to the exact piece that you
will hear so as you are listening to the
music you will see the power spectrum of
waves taken from the frontal channels
where auditory and cognitive processes
are the strongest when the brain signals
emerge the wavy curve at the bottom of
the image will show the signals that
were recorded at that precise moment in
the
music as that signal moves out in time
we can see overall color patterns
perhaps reflecting the changing emotion
of the piece but most importantly sit
back enjoy the piece of music and
consider what activity the music might
be stimulating in your own
brain thank you ladies and gentlemen for
joining us tonight and thank you to the
azrieli foundation and toar for
organizing this evening and making it
possible and let me please remind you to
return your clickers as you leave the
auditorium and please enjoy this final
[Applause]
[Music]
performance
m
[Music]
t
a
[Music]
[Applause]
m
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
oh